guys okay coming out everybody Larry
who's also in first of all they're
loving both my courses one did have the
edge yet the winning team for the main
course congratulations
Wellington all come down to this desert
yesterday our teams trained for the
final course this is the showstopper
when these souffles come out of this
oven and they go in the dining room
you're gonna hear silence across that
room because they're gonna go WOW now
I'm going to show you dessert this is
called panna cotta
we got the passion fruits make sure to
squash the seeds mango icing sugar
orange whisk away it's really good now
how did you come up with this recipe
I've been cooking for 30 [ __ ] Jerry
what usually in the bars where you're at
home kids
eats the oven for minutes now quenelle
hot spoon in and curve and that's gonna
get dropped into the souffle am i ready
to be cure take it off the heat we got
in with the cream in there are we gonna
put the vanilla seeds sugar boil then
orange zest as soon as starts to bubble
then we put the gelatine then these go
straight on yeah look look
quickly quickly start the top in and out
she barking owl arrow you missed the
hole that is amazing this is so good
three hours to the fridge job is done
and I'm gonna show you what they look
like and we're gonna put this on here
now look at this crunchy biscuit for
texture
this one should look like